welcome to the third week of our course
on shaping the future of work now that
we've laid the historical foundation by
looking at what made the social contract
work in our countries in the past it's
time to start to lay out a framework for
the future so this week we're going to
pay special attention to the time when
we first began to identify what made for
high road firms versus low road firms
remember the diagram that we had in the
first chapter of the book that we are
reading for this course where we
identified what differentiates firms
that are perhaps good for shareholders
and produce good financial results but
not such good results for workers
compared to those that produce good
results for both we're going to try to
understand what makes these different
firms work and we're going to see if we
can identify how we can use these ideas
in the future now when we look at these
organizations and we'll bring in
examples like market basket patagonia i
do saturn costco southwest airlines and
others we're not doing that to put these
organizations on a pedestal but really
to dig deeply to understand what makes
them work and how can we apply these in
the industries and organizations of
interest to us and to do that we're
going to really focus on two objectives
this week one is just what I said what
are the ingredients of these high road
firms and then how might we use this
understanding to decide whether or not
we want to work for an employer that has
some of these characteristics will do
that by applying a tool that you'll find
in the assignment tab of the course it's
called a good job survey and it asks you
to go out find a firm of interest to you
or in an industry that you may have a
particular interest in working in talk
to someone talk to an employee in that
firm ask them about the conditions of
work that are present in that
organization you'll find a rating form
you can fill out the form then you
provide your answers on the platform for
the course and down the road we will
report what everyone learned from that
experience we want you to remember these
ideas though because we'll use them
throughout the rest of the course
particularly we're going to put them to
work when we come to the grand finale of
this course where we negotiate a new
social contract the next generation
social contract governing conditions of
employment in our workplaces of the
future so we want you to use some of the
ideas that you learn from both the good
job survey but also from observing and
learning about some of the organizations
that have good practices that we can
then apply in our own organizations so
that's a good deal of what we will do
this week and I hope that you will have
a good time with the materials and that
you'll have a good time applying them as
we go forward but I'd like to make two
quick comments on what we learned from
last week's discussion I was
particularly impressed with the sample
of organizations that you identified as
you went through your career planning
exercise a wide array of very
interesting jobs from engineering clergy
members disability teachers HR managers
labor leaders artists sports agents for
the National Football League nor less
psychometricians people who use
mathematics to try to understand how to
measure individual behavior and
attitudes futurists graphic artists
technical editor's note that all of
these are jobs that really are going to
require considerable human touch
creativity and effort none of these are
going to be totally replaced by robots
or artificial intelligence or machine
learning and so I don't want you to be
too scared about the future of work I
want you to prepare for it that's what
we're learning from this course that's
what we're learning from this particular
exercise so put the pathways of
education that you identified in the
career planning exercise to work do your
part to be prepared for the future and
then
work with us and with other stakeholders
to make sure that the conditions are
present to make it successful I was also
very interested to learn what you had to
say about the great debate over
productivity in wages you completed a
poll and here's the results of that pole
eighty-five percent of you agreed that
wages and productivity ought to move
together about seven percent seven a
half percent said you're not sure and
another seven percent said well maybe
not anymore in fact many of you
indicated while you believe in this
principle you believe it's also going to
be difficult to apply it in the current
economy given changes in technology
changes in international competition and
the the way in which organizations are
structured today but I believe there are
ways we can apply these concepts but we
have to do it in ways that are
consistent with the economy in the
workforce today so I've been added some
more comments on the discussion board
about how we can apply productivity and
wage movements at the national level at
the organizational level even at the
individual level so take a look keep
that great discussion going and let's
see what we can do to apply this concept
appropriately in the economy today and
in the jobs of the future and finally
there are going to be some new ideas
raised by our MBA TAS as they contribute
from their own knowledge and experience
base from around the world and from some
of special experts that we will
introduce into the course on topics as
we go forward this week so have a good
time engage the materials and let's keep
the good conversation going